RFK Jr has just come out and
endorsed some form of reparations for
slavery and I love this story I love
this story some conservatives are really
upset by it I'm not I'm so happy about
it here's what he
said he said we need federal tax dollars
to quote rebuild black infrastructure
like Banks and businesses he supports
quote direct redress payments or tax
credits uh to black people for by virtue
of being black he says communities that
were specifically targeted for
Destruction need to be specifically
targeted for repair during Jim Crow
black Banks businesses hospitals schools
and Farms were targeted for Destruction
racists knew that without these the
black community had no chance of
Building Wealth we must set aside
federal dollars to rebuild black
infrastructure these programs complement
direct redress payments or tax credits
to the descendants of the victims of Jim
Crow and other victims of persecution
RFK Jr will find ways to offer this
redress that are legal fair and win the
approval of Americans all Races okay you
know I hate to say I told you
so I called it I called it when
Americans and when the right-wingers in
particular were saying RFK Jr he's a
right winger that guy he's he's a
Conservative candidate we should back
him over Trump or Dan santis or somebody
I said he's a lib he's a liberal that's
no knock on him exactly he's always been
a liberal his name's Kennedy he just
sides with us on coid vaccines which is
good but there are other issues you know
like the economy and uh abortion and
immigration and National Security and
like everything and everything and he's
with the Liberals on pretty much
everything environmentalism
energy and he happens to be with us on
coid
vaccines to to rfk's point the actual
point he's arguing here he says that
black people were treated unfairly so we
need to give them money in different
forms of course that was the point of
the expansion of the welfare state in
the 60s that was the point of the Great
Society that was the point of the laws
that followed the Civil Rights Act it
was about transferring wealth and
investing in Black infrastructure and
giving handouts and tax credits and
different sorts of things specifically
to black people and it didn't really
improve things at
all so when you hear about a Kennedy
Democrat this is what we're this is
exactly what we're talking about the
Kennedy Democrats have not changed one
iota since the
1960s the problem is those policies from
the 1960s didn't help anything and in
many ways they they hurt the country and
the position of black people so it's
just more of the same but the other
reason I love this story is we've been
told that from all the Geniuses even on
the right they say oh if if RFK Jr runs
he's going to take votes from Trump and
and the reason that people have said
that is because Trump he's a Kookie
populist and RFK Jr he's a Kookie
populist and the Kookie populists are
going to take votes from one
another the people who have the opinion
that RFK Jr was going to take more votes
from Trump than from Biden are the kind
of people who really don't like Trump
and they write off Trump as some
eccentric populist unored man who has no
principles whatsoever who just appeals
to the basis to petitive elements in
society that's not my view of trump I
like some of the other Republicans too
but I I also like Donald Trump and I
have long thought that Donald Trump
appeals to a basically
coherent act in fact rather traditional
kind of American conservatism and
there's a coherence to his political
program even if he sometimes says things
that are somewhat contradictory or
eccentric and therefore if a liberal
comes around he's not going to be able
to pull the wool over the eyes of trump
voters that Trump voters are not as
gullible and deplorable and irredeemable
and whatever else The Establishment
tells us
as the establishment might have us
believe and then guess what you see
polls polling Americans even in certain
decisive places on who they would vote
for if it were Trump versus Biden and
then who they would vote for if it was
Trump versus Biden versus RFK J and
guess who RFK Jr takes more votes from
Guess Who hates to say I told you so it'
be me I'm the one who did it right now
go to expressvpn.com
Michels show it's extremely important to
protect your online privacy with a VPN
and choosing a VPN you trust is equally
as important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here's why number one
expressvpn does not log your online
activity they've developed a trusted
server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up that app and tap one button
to connect not just me saying this
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals raate Express VP the
number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
my link expressvpn.com NOS show today
get three months free on a one-year
package
expressvpn.com
michelow expressvpn.com
Michels show today speaking of the
Republican primary Ronda santis looking
really really good over the weekend as
he evacuates him himself evacuates more
Americans from the Holy Land as War
breaks out happy to report we had
another flight bringing Floridians back
from Israel land in the wee hours of the
morning we've been able to help hundreds
of people get back uh from the war zone
safely to the United States to the State
of Florida uh We've also put a lot of
supplies that have been donated over to
Israel and I know they're really
appreciative of it and we've got another
flight coming uh most likely tomorrow
morning so federal government dragged
its feet a lot of those folks didn't
have any options we stepped up showed
the leadership and are delivering
results
this is the best thing Dan santis can do
for his campaign because it it's also
the thing that's going to give him a
path if this primary doesn't go his
way Ronda santis is never going to beat
Donald Trump at the Charisma
game nobody is it's not it's not even a
knock on De santis nobody is Ronda
santis is not going to beat Donald Trump
on the rhetoric game the santis might
have more controlled or disciplined
rhetoric it's not as exciting Ronda
santz is never going to beat Donald
Trump on the debate game Trump's not
even going to go to the debates D sanis
is not going to beat Donald Trump on the
rally game Trump's always going to have
more exciting
rallies the thing that Ronda santis can
do is get results from his political
office Donald Trump does not currently
have a political office Ronda santis
does so Donald Trump I guess could send
his airplane to as a private citizen to
lift people out of Israel might be kind
of difficult to do Ronda Sanz is
governor of Florida with potentially
constituents and family members of
constituents in the Holy Land he can
send airplanes over there and he can get
results done
and what's great about that strategy is
one if Trump stumbles he'll be able to
point to I've been doing this I've been
doing that I've been very effective I've
been doing my job I'm not just selling
out my second term as Florida Governor
to run for president I'm still getting
stuff done which he's doing and if the
primary doesn't go his way he'll he'll
he won't have completely blown his
career on one failed bid for
president he'll still be able to point
to momentum and achievements he can make
the most of his time in the office that
he's sitting in especially as the
election does not the presidential
election does not appear to be going his
way boy what a great clip that was huh
it was good and what do you do now you
got to ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael n's YouTube channel we'll see
you next time